[Music]
so how many people have heard of
differential privacy anyone it's coming
up in the data news lately if you happen
to have a differential privacy Google
Alert like I do but I'll start off with
me I started off doing radar systems
making maps which is a lot of math not
much privacy at all
then I went here where you'd be
surprised there's actually a lot of
privacy there once they have the data
they don't like people abusing it too
much so actually while I was there I
came up with this or hobbies or
terrorism and I can't drop the mic and
left but actually to combat their
privacy and they have a lot of data
access issues and a lot of reporting
requirements and stuff so we we wrote
this database called accumulo it's very
much HBase with cell level security
built in so so that's one aspect of
privacy as you kind of like build a
giant database all your data will come
here but most most enterprises won't do
that like you know the NSA was able to
do it but they had a four-star general
saying you're gonna do it and I'm not
paying for your Oracle licenses anymore
so that's how they got away with it but
so a group of us left and formed a
company called a Buda and we kind of
took a lot of lessons learned about data
access and privacy and it's not it's not
super sexy machine learning startup but
it's a lot of compliance and governance
and stuff like that yeah people people
still need it and data scientists need
it too yeah so hey that's my next slide
so yeah the GDP why why are we talking
about this stuff the GDP are is coming
this is a snapshot from their website
according to them it's the most
important change of data privacy
regulation and they have this little
doomsday counter on their website and
it's sister you can watch it until you
know I assume most lawyers just watch
this and then when it hits zero they
release the lawsuits and we'll make
money so it's kind of your job to make
sure
you're not focus of that lawsuit I think
it's a data scientist so first thing we
can do we can just kill all the lawyers
and Shakespeare had a good idea there
but really we can just math our way
around this problem so I'm gonna talk
about three scenarios releasing data
collecting data and then interacting
with data privately so releasing data
I'll I'll give you the punchline up
front it's not a good idea
but there's a technique called K
anonymization or where you produce a
release of data just post it out there
on the internet and you and you've
anonymized it though so that you have
guarantees that the individuals can't be
reified and and that sounds good but
it's actually very difficult to achieve
here's a chart out of their initial k
anonymization paper and really the
concept is to generalize your data
enough such that no matter how you group
by you know race birth gender or zip
code the problems are gonna be have
diversity in them so you won't be able
to for instance if you if he grouped by
by this and you had this this group of
white people born in sixty four males if
i knew you're one of those people I
would not know if you had chest pain
obesity or shortness of breath right so
you're kind of your privacy is protected
that way but even in this chart there's
actually a can automation error here you
know you have two people in this group
but they both have the same problem
right so yeah I don't know which one you
are but it doesn't matter because I
still know what your problem is
so this led to what's called El
diversity so that's making sure your K
groups have enough diversity in them and
then you know a paper came out saying
actually that's not good enough you have
to make sure that the diversity in those
groups actually has a statistical
statistically relevant distribution you
know it relevant to the to the overall
population so that's even harder to
trying
maintain for every possible grouping you
know as you add columns this becomes a
nightmare to try and actually do and
then it doesn't guard against the
release of future information either so
if someone else releases more data later
they can't link it to this data and
violate your your privacy so yeah
there's many many attack vectors and
there's papers all over the place so to
drive that point home
AOL do you guys this was awhile ago they
really searched terms of six hundred
fifty thousand users three months of
search terms and they anonymized it and
they said it was fine and researchers
then went through and said hey that's
great thanks for the research data but
other one said all right let's identify
somebody and they did they found user
four four one seven seven four nine
Thommo arnold she's a widow with numb
fingers and a dog that urinates on
everything and even this picture they
found of her has a dog wearing a diaper
confirming that the dog urinates on
everything and this was ranked by CNN as
the 57th dumbest moment in business five
hundred million dollar lawsuit anyone's
name with a c in front of it was like
fired they didn't have a chief data
scientist cuz it wasn't a thing at the
time but i'm sure that they would have
fired him too
so anyway they yeah basically don't do
it and this is kind of what you know the
looming gdpr might be leading to is a
bunch of these lawsuits so how can we
get around this one way is randomized
response and that's a technique Google
and Apple are promoting lately so so
what is this this is a way to collect
sensitive data in a private manner so if
you had the privacy when you collect you
can kind of do what you want with it cuz
because it's built into the data you
have so you have these you have these
cards over here right so I usually try
to come up with a sensitive question to
ask and we'll survey everyone but this
these cards gave me a good opportunity
for privacy so like I'm a big guy
and I'm gonna be staring at whoever puts
a red card over there right and so you
might not want to you know give me a red
card cuz you know I'm watching you and
I'm gonna see you at the happy hour and
I get a couple drinks in me and we're
gonna have words right so you might not
want to do that so instead of everyone
just doing what they really think what
we can do is like everyone roll in
imaginary die and if you know you rolled
a three or if you you know pick a number
between one and six if you pick a three
what you do is you grab a red card and
you throw it in regardless of what you
thought of me that way everyone that
threw a red card in there has this
plausible deniability when I corner you
later you could be like no I was part of
the random thing and I'll be like hey
everyone I'm cornering says they're part
of the random thing but there's no no
way for me to get around that right so
yeah it's this plausible deniability
that you then maintain this isn't the
right formula for three cards and all
these people this is like four you know
yes or no but you know you can do the
math that there's this extra noise in
your data and as long as you have enough
people in or enough samples you can back
out and get at what the true proportion
is so this is what Google has has
published that they're doing they have
this paper called rapport the randomized
aggregate able privacy preserving
ordinal response so what that is is they
take your settings in your Chrome
browser and they add noise to what your
actual settings are before they send
them to Google when you have a chrome
crash and that protects you and however
much you value what your settings are
and your Chrome browser but so they
don't know what your true you know
settings are but they have so many users
that even though they're randomly
flipping settings they can beat those
against each other and find out what the
true settings were you know probably
during this crash they get enough crash
report you get enough settings with
noise
beat it out and and and get at your real
data so that that technique has been
shown to be differentially private and
that's kind of a the gist of this talk
here so differential privacy what is it
it formalizes the idea that a private
computation should not reveal whether
any one person participated in the input
much less what their data was right so
it's a concept where I don't actually
care if I have your data or not the way
I'm doing things I shouldn't care I do
need some data so I do need your data
but if you were to take your particular
data away from me my analysis wouldn't
change and this is a quote from Frank
McSherry who's actually your keynote
speaker in this session tomorrow right
and he's great you should come listen to
him
like whatever he says it's probably
gonna be funny and entertaining and he's
not talking about differential privacy
but he's kind of one of the original
authors of the concept so yeah any hard
questions you have for me
ask Frank tomorrow so so what is
differential privacy so the formal
definition is you have these two data
sets that vary by one entry data data
one in data two you have this this
single entry here and you want to
perform some aggregation across that
data a query of that data and here's the
formal definition is so you have the
probability that that query on dataset
one just is differs by the result of
that query on data set to by this e to
the epsilon factor so that's kind of
kind of a weird formula to get a get
your get a hold of and it doesn't really
tell you how to do queries or how to how
to do anything with this Epsilon so
let's get into that yeah can we have
that in words so what this is doing is
treating privacy for usability and that
e to the epsilon is generally an
addition of some random noise to the
query results
so this this M factor here forces you to
only have aggregate queries so there's
no select star limit 1 million putting
on my laptop and let's have fun that
doesn't exist in this world
but that's fine what what this does do
though it protects against all past
current and future data releases and
you're gonna get statistically the same
result regardless of any single entry in
the database or not in that database so
and if you're asked the right questions
you're gonna get the right result even
though it's gonna have noise but you
know
congratulations like if your data
scientists your your data is already
like some noisy sample of some infinite
reality we have here anyway so what's a
little bit more noise because your data
even though we're this is the data
engineering conference and I'm sure
there's great data engineers here all
all data it just kind of sucks and it's
noisy right so that's why we have jobs
so so differential privacy basically you
come up with a way to add noise and then
you go through mathematically improve
that that way is differentially private
and hopefully it's useful to so one such
method is is this laplacian method it's
the widest used method and basically you
take your query result and take a random
draw from this laplacian distribution
and you add it to your result the
laplacian has this one factor here and
we set it to this Delta M over epsilon
so epsilon is your privacy parameter
that's how much variability you want in
your query chosen by you up for debate
what it should be
somewhere around one ish if it's 10
you're gonna kind of kill this to
nothing and Delta M so what's this Delta
M is your sensitivity of your of your
query and your data so in excuse me in
yeah in basic terms sensitivity is
kind of the the maximum of the
difference of any query on that one data
set and any query on that other data set
and the easy example here is is like the
housing market if you have a bunch of
houses on your block except for the one
guy at the top of the street has this
mansion and you want to protect the
individual values of the homes on this
block but we want to you know be able to
summarize this block somehow privately
so what you do is if you if you look at
the that mean of this it's not very
sensitive because if you throw any one
of these houses out of the mean
calculation or more likely if you throw
this 30 million dollar house out of the
mean calculation it's gonna change the
mean widely so you have to adjust your
noise to that huge 30 million dollar
swing so to properly do that you would
have to return the answer of basically
30 million plus noise all the time no
matter what question was asked because
you're asking for that mean so that the
median is a much a much better question
to ask of this data set because no
matter what house you throw out the
median house is only gonna vary by about
you know ten thousand dollars or so so
since that variability is only ten
thousand you have to add noise
proportionally to that variability so
you're gonna get a better result and
still protect the privacy of the 30
million without saturating any
usefulness with noise so all right
aggregate statistics I know like that
gave me heartburn at first too I can
only do aggregations but paper was just
released of people working on
differential privacy in conjunction with
uber and they they did a giant survey
around an uber of all their queries and
they found that 34 percent or these
statistical aggregate queries right and
the rest of them were these raw data and
select queries
and I have zero evidence for this but I
assume that's like data engineers being
lazy and just doing select stars for
their ETL out of this database that
people are actually trying to do real
statistics on and they should they
should do that
ETL somewhere else anyway but that's
just my conjecture to make my opinion of
statistical queries look better so yeah
eight million queries and it's actually
kind of kind of cool data that they've
that they published so huh how's another
method of just randomly doing this query
and adding this noise how can we control
that noise a little bit better and this
is kind of what what we've worked on
it's a paper they don't have referenced
here but I can send that out it's it's
called the sample and aggregate method
so what you do is you have a lot of data
and you break it into samples and you
run that query on each sample
independently and then you look at the
results of those independent queries and
you aggregate them together and add
noise in a private way and what that
does is if you're if you're able to
break your query up and look for
averages and and if the average is
always you know the same or something or
the counts are very similar among all
those groups then that query is not very
sensitive kind of by definition like you
asked it independently to a bunch of
different people and you always got the
same answer well then I can just release
that same answer if you remove any piece
of data from any one of those samples
and I still gonna get the same answer I
can you know accurately release that
data and then you know likewise if it's
if it's not you you can get a
measurement of how much noise you have
to add so what this is doing is instead
of looking at the query itself where
there is the mean or the median or a
count you know account has a sensitivity
of one and what you can do is focus it
on the data you actually have so it's
kind of flipping the script a little bit
to the data rather than then the query
itself but there are other things you
can do with differential privacy so it
so it is more useful
- so this is the Gini coefficient it
measures this type of imbalance
typically in payroll data or wealth the
top one percent if you will and you know
here's a definition of this curve from
Wikipedia but if everyone made the same
amount of money you'd have this nice
curve here it's this cumulate cumulative
share of people from low to high and
then the share of their income earned
for that population so we actually did
this using our differential privacy data
source and you know broke up the
salaries into small groups and we're
able to match the the private versus on
private pretty closely so we know that
there is this imbalance in our payroll
data and we haven't you know found out
who's the cause of it we just kind of
know the degree of it so yeah you kind
of have to have to do higher level
higher order statistics lots of
aggregates and stuff but there's still a
lot of statistics out there you can do
with differential privacy we've tried to
make the tool and this is where we're
working on it like sometimes it there's
a fine line between telling you know
that was too specific and telling you
and just giving you a crazy number back
right hopefully you're gonna recognize
that it's a crazy number you get back
when we do that but but that's still an
area we're working on right yeah but
we're in this world of machine learning
have you guys seen this comic yet that's
Casey be you know this is your machine
learning system yeah you just shove data
in to this linear algebra and if it
looks wrong you just kind of stir up the
algebra until it looks right and you
know clearly we're doing image
recognition this convoluted mess must be
private but I have bad news for you it's
not so machine learning is all
vulnerable to privacy attacks - one is
this model and version attack where
they're really able to extract your
model parameters and your training data
out of your
out of your model itself by you know
basically running other neural nets
against your network right and what
they're able to do is extract this
generic face is the model from this this
face recognition system they attacked
and yeah it's kind of blurry but you can
kind of see a face in there and then
sure enough this is one of the faces
that was in the training data set so
yeah so machine learning has been shown
to be to be be able to violate privacy
in those situations to another machine
learning differentially private system
is similar to the sample and aggregate
but kind of on a higher order machine
level machine learning level what they
did was this is Nicolas paper now from
Penn State did this and what they did
was basically they they took all this
data and they formed a bunch of neural
networks trained a bunch of them in
parallel and separated the data so these
aren't seeing any of the same datasets
and then you have this aggregate teacher
and in teaching this teacher what
they're doing is that they injected
noise here kind of this e to the epsilon
noise in this process and you know then
that then the teacher can be queried
and it's and it's been shown to be
private so that's kind of cool but you
need then like 10x the data and 10x the
training of the models and it's a big
10x problem but but you get privacy as
the result so here's his experimental
result the non private versus the
private on the feminist data set in the
street view signs some of it wasn't
wasn't awesome but here's the the golden
boy result here is this on the UCI
diabetes data set they were actually
able to get slightly better results with
this 1.4 times 1.4 for EPS
one privacy parameter so and they
surmise that the addition of the noise
is actually you know killing your
overfitting and your you know the
memorization that these things tend to
do so maybe it's not such a bad idea to
just like inject noise into this process
and I hope I see more more papers where
people are doing that to maintain
privacy
so yeah summary is laws are catching up
to your data science but we can do
better math we can make better models we
can add noise generally I know when I
talk to data scientists they don't
really care about the individuals in
their data sets the data scientists at
the NSA definitely cared about the
individuals in the data sets but um but
in general you know you're just looking
at clique patterns and you just want to
know you know who I am and how I can
click on something not Who I am
specifically like what what drives me to
click so yeah I think that's all I got
here's my contact info I'll get the
thing finished a little fast in half an
hour so people have questions we can do
questions let's think Jim real quick
[Music]
some questions from so what if you
happened to work with a lot of data that
is intended for CRM or customer
relations marketing or management
depending on how you want to view at the
end part where it is I mean you can do a
lot of analysis but specifically or
you're asking these people to give you
their data you confuse it statistically
to a lot of other data sets and
obviously we have a lot of lawyers
working on making sure that that's all
cool but I care a lot about privacy and
I would like to be able to apply these
principles to customer relation
marketing data so that we're not
annoying so I understand you're looking
to like on the collection aspect like
we're gonna do a machine learning model
to say like hey you really like concerts
with whatever terrible pop artist
we need to remarket to you how how
should we be thinking about anonymizing
that and protecting those people's
information while still utilizing it as
as a company for our benefit right it's
like yeah it's a tough balance right so
that's what differential privacy does is
it is it trades that usability is what
you would call it for privacy so to
break it to you you're gonna have to
give up some usability but maybe not so
if you can come up with statistics that
are aggregations and break those the
data you have into big enough groups
that you can do meaningful aggregations
and then train models like kind of on
higher-order statistics that were
developed differentially private they
have noise generated on them or you know
towards the end is is doing a
differentially private machine learning
model and in and of itself you know to
be able to class a private classifier so
it's going to be like kind of new
techniques that have noise injected into
the training process
we definitely do it the other thing is
is sorry just to combine techniques I
mean differential privacy is kind of
like the hammer that throws away
usability but you can do anonymization
techniques I mean they are good they're
just not perfectly private and since its
internal like you know that kind of
helps like you know I wouldn't say post
that on your github as hey help us
analyze this and the next Kangol thing
because people are gonna be anonymized
advertiser like obviously they're
probably gonna turn it around and give
it to advertisers where I've worked and
I know what advertisers do with data as
well so it's kind of how do I as a data
scientist make sure and data engineer
make sure that I'm protecting the data
that we're collecting from what the
people in marketing are gonna do with it
right well so if you can do it on the
collection side that that would be good
too is to add noise to the collection
process then you as a data scientist
have to beat that noise out on the back
end so then it never exists at the
company right on private so my question
was on the actual collection portion of
it I mean you mentioned these techniques
would be used for at aggregate level but
is there any noise that we could add to
you know for CRM we probably can't
because we have to service the customer
but is there anything we could do on the
storage of these customer records you
know you mentioned gdpr and other things
but at a granular like record level yeah
during the collection process I actually
don't have your data I have some you
have your data annoys I can't identify
you from it that does that answer
you can't add it to the plan like
addresses and zip codes we can't like
add noise to them because we have to
service them later right right yeah I
mean you would have to you know bubble
up addresses to the block or the city or
something like that you've been using
normalization techniques to bubble it up
and then you can look at those the key
anonymization work to figure out how
much you have to bubble it up such that
when you get down to things how much is
left over and and identifiable when
you're done but that is there's some
work to prove that to yourself I really
don't know if many companies are gonna
like care until this law hits them and
you're able to show you know a definite
company I've spent a lot of time working
with data and data has meaning because
the context that it's in so a piece of
private data is private because there's
a context which identifies a specific
person or thing based on that data
the anonymization of data assumes that
you can bound the context in a
meaningful way and I think Big Data is
antithetical to that that ultimately
regardless of how much effort you put
into anonymizing your data if there's
any meaning in that data eventually
somebody's gonna be able to discover and
exploit it right yeah that's true and
that's why like that Kay anonymization
just doesn't work like eventually
there's gonna be other data that's gonna
reveal you know the problem in your
privacy
[Music]